der hass von rechtsextremen terrorist
berichtet sich gegen juden muslime und
andersdenkende mein name ist anders denn
bei holocaust was wäre wenn er durch die
tür hindurch gekommen wären wäre ich
noch am leben
stephan pariert attackierte mit
selbstgebauten waffen im oktober 2009 10
an der synagoge in halle tötete zwei
menschen und streamt die seine amokfahrt
live ins netz als ein star dastehen der
sich den weg frei zwischen
verschwörungstheorien rechtsextrem chat
gruppen und wassen bauplänen alles
bündeln wollen auf den augenblick wo sie
endlich herr über leben und tod sind wo
sie die panik in den augen der opfer
sehen
[Musik]
wer das notwendige rüstzeug dafür haben
möchte der kann sich das in deutschland
ungehindert beschaffen
[Musik]